[Music]
in the peaceful town of santa fe new
mexico on the quiet street of rufina
circle you will find a beautiful
victorian home where two great artists
are having a very casual conversation
how do we push the boundaries of our
reality and how do we access the chaotic
unknown
yeah
very casual indeed
to find their answers emily and katie
had the courage to go to places few have
ever been
this great big story is by geico believe
it geico could save you 15 or more on
car insurance
welcome to the house of eternal return
an immersive art exhibit built by the
art collective meow wolf
and these are katie and emily who are
there when everything started we wanted
to create that space of pure
self-expression and we just wanted to
make stuff forever
the year was 2008 when a group of
radical artists wanted to make art with
no rules they decided to get together
and put a name to the project meow wolf
fast forward three years and they were
commissioned for their first interactive
art exhibit and it was a huge success
meow wolf was in business but business
meant rules
eventually we had to adapt in order to
grow
now our story is reflected in the
narrative of the house oh can i hear the
story i'll give you the short version
thank you
the house of eternal return is a story
about order and chaos
the anomaly a creative but mindless
force of chaos and shadow people who
represent order rules and structure
so
you guys the artists you with the
anomaly well actually we're both the
anomaly and the shadow people because we
have this like vision that we wanted to
bring into the world and it was crazy
and unrealistic but we realized in order
to do that we had to provide the
structures to support it ah just like
the shadow people that's right
[Music]
so
[Music]
and so life goes on here at ravina
in perfect yet delicate balance between
order
and chaos
[Music]
you